desperate for answers these migrants
have been waiting for months for their
applications to be processed they're
searching for safety and a better life
there are people like me who cannot go
back because we have suffered a lot of
violence in our country we have endured
a lot and if we go back we will die we
have decided to wait and see what
happens and see what decisions the u.s
government will take
u.s president joe biden suspended the
remaining mexico program calling it
inhumane but a court order has forced it
to be reinstated
former president donald trump used to
the policy then known as the migrant
protection protocols to send more than
70 000 asylum applicants back to mexico
where they were forced to wait for
months human rights groups reported
several cases of kidnapping rape and
torture
but the white house says improvements to
the scheme will give asylum seekers
legal representation this program is has
endemic flaws it imposed it has imposed
unjustifiable human costs pulled
resources and personnel away from other
priority efforts and failed to address
the root causes of a regular irregular
migration deeply flawed
under guidance from mexico the u.s will
now provide covert 19 vaccinations and
exemptions such as for those with
physical and mental health challenges
the first migrants are expected to be
returned from the states of texas and
california this shelter is preparing for
a massive influx of people
we are preparing to increase our
capacity at the shelter we had a
capacity of 150 now we want to have a
capacity of more than two hundred
thousand migrants because we believe
that there'll be a mobilization towards
the northern border
while there is deep concern about the
return of the policy some remain hopeful
they can still begin a new life with
their families
it's really hard to be waiting and now
again with the migrant protection
protocols but i think it is a really
good thing because we have the hope to
get another opportunity to wait and see
if they let us cross into the u.s and be
with our families
the mexican government has said it's
committed to maintaining the health and
safety of asylum seekers as the new
program gets underway these migrants are
hoping those promises are kept
hamara choutri al jazeera